now of course everyone's hyped up for
this year's iphone 13
since there's only a few months left
until september but
what if some people would be better off
sticking with their current phones
for just one more year because of how
game changing
the 2022 iphones are expected to be i
know that sounds crazy
but the leaks and rumors that i'm about
to show you are so
impressive that you might actually end
up skipping the iphone 13
and trust me you're gonna be surprised
now most of the leaks right now
are pointing to the iphone 13 finally
having a smaller notch
by moving the speaker grille right up
next to the frame
and reducing the width of the notch
which is very exciting
but the truth is that the notch is still
going to be there
and it's still a bit distracting on top
of that some analysts believe that it's
going to be an
s year so it might actually be called
the iphone 12
s but the main point is that there won't
really be
drastic changes coming to this year's
iphones
there will probably be some nice tweaks
and upgrades like finally getting 120hz
support
stronger mac safe magnets and in display
touch id
but things like the cameras won't be
drastically changing
just getting some minor improvements and
this all makes sense because we just got
a full super cycle redesign with the
iphone 12
so we can't expect too many hardware
changes
but i believe that 2022 is when apple is
going
all out with their iphones including a
brand new iphone model that we've never
seen before
so let's get right into it way back in
2019
ming chakra correctly leaked the iphone
12 lineup
and within that leak he also mentioned
that the highest end iphone in 2021
would have no lightning port now he
initially mentioned that it would be
completely
wireless but i personally disagree with
that because of a patent that apple
filed
showing a new magnetic connector which
replaces lightning
so we made a full video on that but i
believe that it's likely that apple will
switch to this
new wired magsafe connector before they
would go
fully portless since this connector will
be able to transfer
data while improving convenience and
water resistance
now whether or not this happens for the
iphone 13 pro max this year
i'm not sure but we did also have a
rumor from john prosser
saying that we will have at least one
portless iphone model
in 2021 but either way i'm very
confident that we will be seeing
this new magnetic port coming to the
iphone 14 lineup in 2022
basically making it portless since a
connector is technically
not a port now moving on we have a very
interesting
and kind of hard to believe leak from
inchikwo he says that at least
the high-end 2022 iphones will be
getting a
hole punch display design similar to a
lot of the higher-end samsung phones
like the s21 ultra now this is a bit
hard to believe
because apple would have to figure out a
way to move the face
id sensors and components away from the
display area
to get rid of the notch since we're
pretty sure apple will continue to use
face id
for many many years now since most of
the iphone 13 leaks
show that the speaker grille is being
moved to the top literally right next to
the frame
i personally believe that the best way
for apple to do this
is to split the sensors apart and fit
them on both sides of the speaker grille
allowing for a nice and thin bezel and
then on top of that
quo mentioned that he expects at least
one iphone in 2023
to have a full screen display with no
notch
and no holes which is the dream now a
couple of months back
digitimes claimed that the lighter
scanner that we currently have
on the iphone 12 pro models will be
expanding to the entire iphone 13
lineup but i find that hard to believe
because lidar just came out
with the 12 pro and recent leaks are
also pointing to the less expensive 13
models
not getting lidar as you can see in this
leaked
cad image but based on that i fully
expect the entire iphone 14 lineup
to get lidar in 2022 so that's
definitely something to look forward to
now moving on we're basically 100 sure
that the iphone 13 pro models
this year will be getting 120 hertz
refresh rate on the displays
and because of that there are some
people expecting the entire iphone 14
lineup next year
getting 120 hertz but in my opinion i
don't see that happening until at least
2023
the reason for that is because apple
first released promotion 120 hertz
back in 2017 for the 10.5 inch ipad pro
and now almost four years later the only
apple product with 120 hertz is the ipad
pro
not even the new ipad air that was just
released a few months ago
so because of that it seems like apple
wants to keep the high refresh rate a
pro exclusive feature
at least for now so i expect apple to
only give it to the low end iphones in
2023 at least just to make the pros feel
more exclusive and at that point the
pros will probably have 240hz refresh
rate
since apple actually won a patent for an
iphone display with variable refresh
rate
up to 240hz now the same thing goes for
another leak from digitimes
claiming that every iphone 13 model will
be getting
sensor shift stabilization this year i
once again think that just the iphone 13
pros
are gonna have this feature including
the smaller model
and then next year it's gonna come down
to every iphone 14 model
and on top of that since tsmc's three
nanometer chips are expected to hit
volume production
in 2022 we can for sure expect powerful
3 nanometer a15 chips in the iphone 14
lineup but now
let's get into the very juicy leaks that
prove that the 2022 iphones
are going to be absolutely game-changing
ming chi ko says that the iphone 14 pro
models will get a
48 megapixel main camera that's capable
of shooting
8k video now this is a huge deal because
for the past
five years iphones have been strictly
limited to a 12 megapixel main camera
even the brand new 12 pro max and even
better
quo says that apple will use pixel
binning to merge the 48 megapixel output
down into a 12 megapixel photo which
will essentially make the pixel size
a massive 2.5 micrometers larger than
what
any smartphone can do bringing it close
to professional camera quality
for low light imagery this in the new 8k
video recording feature will essentially
bring smartphone photography to a whole
new level
and it would basically bring ak video to
the mainstream
since the industry usually follows in
apple's footsteps
now on top of that ming also mentioned
that the 5.4 inch iphone mini size
will be discontinued in 2022
and that's of course due to the very low
sales numbers
that the current 12 mini has which
ultimately led to us making this review
showing off why it failed now with that
if apple's getting rid of the mini size
then what are they going to replace it
with well apparently makeshift says that
there will actually be
two large 6.7 inch iphone 14 models next
year a
low end model and a high-end pro model
which is really really weird i
personally have a hard time believing
this because currently
the people who want a large display have
to pay extra for the pro max model
and that means extra revenue for apple
but with what quo is saying people can
get a large display
for a cheaper price so because of that i
have a totally
different theory what if the second 6.7
inch iphone
is actually a foldable iphone
now i know that sounds crazy but let me
explain we've been getting leaks about
apple's foldable phone for months or
even years now
with everything ranging from patents for
the hinge system to even
sending foldable phones to foxconn for
durability testing
and these leaks started way back in 2017
especially with this patent image of a
foldable iphone
with a flexible display but then on the
other hand
they also applied for patents for a
larger ipad mini like display
with two separate panels instead of a
flexible panel
so here's my theory what if apple is
actually working on
two foldable iphones and the first one
that's been rumored to be coming in 2022
will have a flexible 6.7 inch display
that folds vertically like a flip phone
like you see in this image and this
could totally go in line with a report
from the verifier last year
claiming that a new foldable iphone is
coming in 2022
for 1500 which actually seems like a
reasonable price
this makes total sense because last year
it was reported
that two different foldable iphone
prototypes passed
internal durability testing so i did a
little digging and i found that john
prosser is thinking along the same lines
as i am
but obviously before i realize this one
flip phone style foldable
and one larger foldable so i personally
believe
that next year apple is going to release
a 6.7 inch iphone
flip with a flexible display for around
fifteen hundred dollars
and then in the future maybe 2023 or 24
they'll release the larger foldable that
has two separate panels
so yeah i told you that next year is
gonna be
world changing for apple but beyond that
manchester is also expecting an iphone
se3 model
coming in the first half of 2022 but it
looks like it's going to maintain
the same 4.7 inch display for at least
another year and apparently
ross young believes we'll be getting a
fully redesigned
se model in 2023 with a 6.1 inch display
and a hole punch camera instead of a
notch so there you guys go
that's basically everything you should
expect in terms of 2022 and future
iphones
and i've got to say it's going to be an
absolutely killer year for apple
because they're going to be changing the
smartphone camera game
with the new 48 megapixel camera and
they'll basically make foldable phones
mainstream
by releasing the iphone flip so
hopefully you guys enjoy this video and
if you disagree with anything that i
said
leave a comment down below but if you
enjoyed it go ahead and tap the like
button
and click the circle about to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there
thank you for watching and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]